we should do a tutorial okay hey what's
up everybody it's your boy Zack and
Fernando and today we're gonna be doing
an Instagram nail tutorial I have never
done my nails ever in my life No hell no
no I don't do nails I don't do nail
maintenance either so we're figuring in
design on Instagram for each other and
then we're gonna go out to our
colleagues and find out who did the best
I came in knowing that you were gonna
win why not did pay my nails which was
one time or I should say somebody
painted my nails that one oh yeah
[Music]
I'm highly competitive so even though I
know nothing about this I'm absolutely
gonna win I will win
this is all I'm gonna have you do okay I
can do that it seems like hard but like
not too hard I left nail open nail for I
am rolling with this one for you North
as a beginning art student maybe this
would be something that's easy for you
to do I just want you to have a fighting
chance in this competition I hate you I
would never wear yellow and teal it
looked like Denver Nuggets Jersey Denver
Nuggets do I look like a Denver Nuggets
fan no exactly
initial thoughts that seems really hard
very cheetah girl realness oh I love the
cheetah girls you literally just have to
do like three dots oh it is it's not a
messy huh it's my my feeling I got away
with yeah I messy one for a messy boy I
put some thought into it you like some
sci-fi stuff you like a space I thought
this was actually a well thought-out
design for you I very much love this if
I had my nails done this is something I
would do to him I already get started
yeah we have no other choice
let's do it in about 10 minutes we're no
longer gonna be basic Oh Oh what I need
the CLO and I need purple this color
what is all this stuff what are these
for they're just fine it's like a little
paint mini paintbrush and you go like
that oh yeah that would make sense
yeah the laughter you guys are laughs
leads me to believe that I didn't think
this was for nails no I didn't I didn't
at all is this how I be painting them no
these come with a brush inside another I
knew that I'm gonna go for it oh my god
oh my god yeah there's a punch it's oh
there's a brush in here bro yeah what'd
you think oh I've seen nail polish
before I clearly you have not do I shake
is it smart if I just do the whole nail
yellow and then put stuff up is it gonna
drop you're supposed to do I don't know
how fast it drunk where are you gonna
put the yellow around the circle's is
that what you were thinking I don't know
how fast it dries okay
further review it says insta-dry I'm
putting on a nice layer of black I want
to talk like Bob rice I really wanted to
talk like Bob rice right now right now
I'm applying a thick coat of yellow to
the nail region how much am I supposed
to put on you know what I can do oh not
that much okay I'm feeling great
oh this is okay this is intense I
already messed this up look look at this
this is ridiculous it looks like it just
ain't a hot dog with a lot of mustard on
it and so the leftovers the issue with
mine is that she has a tiny black line
right there and I'm feeling good this
doesn't look great but I'm feeling good
I'm gonna use a piece of paper to stay
in the light
I had it some purple in there does not
look how I thought it was gonna look it
legit looks like you put your hand in
mustard right now maybe that's the
aesthetic that I'm trying to afford
I'm a hot mess at a hot dog I'm trash
insta-dry is maybe the biggest lie I'm
trying to dry it so then I can put more
of the yellow on so it really pops
maybe if I leave my fingers down like
this it would be easier I could do this
on you and it would look great but like
I'm using my right hand I'm like
I write with my left hand I do things
with boats so I've never painted my
nails so I don't know which one it's
easier with this hand I be utilizing the
toothpick oh we got toothpicks I flipped
the toothpick to use not the sharp side
of it because it's more of a circle Wow
grand breaking I'm gonna let you know
something if you mess up don't try to
just go over what you messed up with
with a different nail polish because
that just makes it worse how do you know
this because I just did it this is
coming together this is happening I
think I can do this you seem very
focused over there learning from my
mistakes patience I will say I think
they use thinner brushes for this
because I don't like okay so see this
time I went and I did all the rest of my
fingers with that black base so now I
can just go through and boom hit them
with the purple and hit them with the
white purple
I'm not doing great but like here's the
thing this is like when you're writing a
research paper and on your second page
you realize that your thesis statement
was crap you're like damn I'm too deep
and to go back so I'm just gonna tweak
it a little bit yeah change my sources
then there I'm having a lot of fun right
now it's soothing to the soul even
though I'm doing it horribly I really
like the paint going onto my nail and me
focusing on the brush hitting my nails
so vividly off how do you get a specific
amount of nail polish you don't have any
say it's like this is how much you get
you just deb-deb into it we should do
tutorial okay
hey what's up everybody it's your boy
zack and Fernan
and today we're gonna be doing an
Instagram nail tutorial alright guys so
what you're gonna need today is
definitely a very important document
that you don't need anymore so you could
have straight lines on your nails I know
we're competing but people this time
with the friend holding down the paper
you're gonna want to put the wine like
that okay then your frame will remove
the paper okay oh wow that's not bad is
it bad I had better expectations oh then
you're gonna touch it up with some white
kind of like cute cover that yeah you're
very much on your skin I'm struggling a
little bit but that makes me relatable
I'm moving on to no wait wait for me
wait for me sack Jesus sorry guys oh my
gosh those we never do that we never
fight we're perfect
we're very competitive I love sports you
paint the nails don't let the nails
paint you paint those nails Chris paint
them damn I've got my base on the rest
of my fingers time to add some stars my
hope is that if I just add a bunch of
the glittery one people will be like oh
his has shiny colors right now I'm
finishing up the spots there seems to be
some blue on top of the black I'm
totally going outside of the lines but
you know what I don't believe in
restrictions wow I'm impressed look at
that like a leopard I have mad respect
for nail artists because this is
terribly difficult it's incredibly
difficult he bleeding what happened I
wanted to prove that I could do a solid
one but I can't this is like painting on
five little tiny canvases five
opportunities to mess up and I feel like
I've screwed up a little bit in a
different way on each nail finished I
decided to go for like a messy look I
know that's very in right now and
Instagram the messy look is like
something that people really like like
you don't you didn't try hard but this
is what we got this is my finished
product we are both done this is what
I'm working with here this
my finished product five lovely galaxies
and some mustard I think they look
better than what I thought I would do
but definitely not as good as the
Instagram I agree I actually am very
impressed with your nail painting skills
and then slightly disappointed with my
are you impressed with you now there's
no I'm far from impressed I think they'd
be like the silver lining if you liked
them I hate myself for doing this work
it was easier than I expected it was
much harder than I expected nail polish
is tough to control I have no skills
whatsoever being very hard on yourself
today you might win you know this makes
me respect all the men and women who
paint their nails yeah I feel like I
just go oh their nails are painted there
knows what it's like no you have to be
good at it all right you can't do it in
fairness when I show people this next to
the example they're gonna be like that
looks nothing like it where's yours is
like yeah oh no they're gonna say that
bad enough she'll show the office not
really brinda you can at least clean it
up
I don't know Brennan oh it's just like I
can't say yes I think I can I get a
point yeah I think you get a point from
disappoint here you can see them both
Chris oh this is what I was supposed to
do all right
this is why I would definitely go with
these based on how clean I'm just gonna
have to go with that because you didn't
go outside the lines he stayed in three
lines mostly Chris Krista he think he's
got less paint on his fingers like yours
could have been like you went to a salon
and the lady wasn't that good
Oh so I'm Salaam worthy yeah I am
clearly not a long word Theo what are
you laughing at
looks like the fourth of July threw up
thinking very American very Lana Del Rey
he does look better but you might have
had an advantage thing I think Kristen a
little bit better
my name is Lia descent okay looks like
outer space outer space what is this
simply like abstract outer space
it's like finger-painting in
kindergarten who won you did hashtag
which is my best finger yeah that one
cuz you have a little member than the
naked nail if anyone off just do that
yeah okay thank you
so I'm quitting yeah I will never do it
again this just made me feel bad I
probably won't do it again because I
feel like just doing it this one time I
really nailed it you get it nailed
[Music]